ooh you have to get up now something
really awesome to show you t-shirt dick
on my face we are going to go this in
for your birthday we deserve this on
order asses oh no it's gonna [ __ ]
beach no you have to work tomorrow
sucks for y'all yeah we're at the beach
next week you're not hitting up our
dog's party we have to see Rodrick sober
ladies be here morning where'd you get
[ __ ] up with him just like hang for a
min and say hey
[Music]
is this seriously are you coming to work
you're high as [ __ ] you cannot leave me
alone here because I will literally die
no I'm disappointed you to work right
honey
working hard entertaining this hair one
of the only things about this place I
don't hate go do something with you guys
I'm not going anywhere without you what
the [ __ ] are you doing that's a decency
y'all are dirty dirty girls what
that's so stupid no you are no stupid
not be able to use a goddamn bathroom
for today's if it's a [ __ ] jail go
yet no I told you I couldn't you went
last night there's no privacy no place
you know that that's not healthy
[Music]
[Music]
you